the infectious diseases expert professor
debbie bogart from the university of
edinburgh good morning professor bergart
um good morning there
nicholas sturgeons issued
this warning can you quantify that how
bad could it be
well i think the the data that we have
so far showed us clear
what we've called already for 20 months
or so exponential growth of this new
strain so we have this train only for
less than two weeks and if you see that
this trend goes from one percent to two
percent to four percent to eight percent
to sixteen percent that clearly shows an
exponential growth and the interesting
thing here is that it takes all these
little steps um
every two to three days so if from today
that this was friday so
let's say today the amount of uh cases
that is explained by omicron is back 30
um we can be as high as 100 percent of
all cases being explained by omicron
halfway this week so it clearly shows
that we we
can potentially face a tsunami of cases
so i fully agree with that
what is your view about this uh
discussion we've been having pretty much
all morning about whether um the
symptoms uh are gonna be milder out of
this uh variant or not uh
is what you're seeing telling you
anything on that
topic
well i think everybody is is
saying we should be cautious and i agree
fully with that um we have a new variant
that we know
um
can infect people with um pre-existing
immunity through a recent infection uh
by delta and also in fact people that
have been even double um immunized
so but we assume that that immunity that
they have will protect them uh in part
against uh severe disease but also with
delta we've seen we still have quite a
significant amount of people in in
hospital i think we're about 6000 cases
at the moment isn't it in hospital in in
the entire uk so even if omicron would
be slightly milder if this exponential
growth keeps on continuing because a
much larger proportion of the population
is susceptible we can ultimately face
quite an overwhelming number of cases
anyway in the hospital so yeah the good
news is we might be either because the
strain is perhaps
causing milder illness or less severe
cases and we might be partially
protected by our pre-existing immunity
if the doubling time and the number of
cases keep on continuing like they're
doing now we might still reach
very large numbers and even if a small
proportion of those get
um require hospitalizations
we might get quickly overwhelmed and i
agree that we need to um see how this
all pans out in the coming weeks but i
don't think that if we really want to be
ahead of the game we have weeks to sit
down and wait to see what's happening so
we
probably need to act act pretty fast to
be ahead of the game
so is it your view that what we need to
do is to behave as though
the nhs is likely to be overwhelmed by
the combination of uh existing delta
cases plus what might happen
out of omicron and if we're lucky we
won't have that but that we have to now
behave as though that's the case
yeah exactly i think everybody heard the
number of one million cases that could
potentially our theory be reached uh by
christmas and um i think we all can feel
that that's way too much and would way
overwhelm the system um let alone um
have a lot of people being put into
isolation not being able to to celebrate
christmas
we have already measures in place we
have already um immunity in place so we
need to up our game i think
um so i think the first thing we we have
that we didn't have a year ago are the
vaccines so i would
ask everyone either if you had zero one
or two vaccines to try to quickly get
the next vaccine because if as a
community we can up our community
immunity we hopefully can push that
virus a bit down and slow it down uh out
of that rapid exponential growth and the
other thing is i i you know the measures
in scotland is now that if you have a
case in the in in the household that you
need to self-isolate as a household and
although i agree um people might not
like that it's the best thing to do
um over the last days data came from
england showing that household
transmission of this strain is three
times as high as from delta so that
means you can't you can't um
um let this
this go or take that chances so it's
definitely a measure that hopefully
helps to reduce this red
so so you would you would argue for
slightly tougher measures would you uh
also
support the vaccination of primary
school children now
yeah and there are several countries
already that do immunize primary school
children it's definitely a discussion
that we hear um um too little
um it's um the chain is as weak as the
weakest link i would say from an
immunity uh perspective and we still
have many children that have no
protection
by vaccination so we have a safe vaccine
and i think it would be wise to really
quickly consider
whether parents have the choice to get
their children from the age of five up
immunized but also the children 12 up
that had only one vaccine or none at all
yet i would um actually advise to go and
get that um shot the first or the second
and everybody who already got one or two
shots to get the second or the third
and otherwise i think we really need to
up again with the measures we already
have think about masking i really think
everybody should really
follow um that advice and in crowded
places where you can't keep distance
mask up not only over the mouth but also
over the nose and preferably very well
fitting
mask and if it's crowded you can't keep
your distance uh you could even consider
a a higher rate mask in ffp2 as they
call it or even double mask because we
really anticipate that we will help uh
uh limited
just very briefly uh professor burgh if
i may just ask you very briefly uh you
may have heard my interview our
interview with um
steve baker mp earlier on and he
essentially said that we have to trust
people we have to give people freedom
that the question of restrictions is
really a moral one how does a scientist
respond to that
yeah as a scientist and a doctor i know
that people
like to have a choice but also want to
be well informed and want to be able to
weigh
uh their decisions based on the facts
and i think what we can do is show the
fact show how significant this is how
quickly this can get out of hand and ask
them to really work with us to try to
limit the spread it's not only and a
general um um
uh benefit but also in people's
individual benefits because we want to
celebrate christmas after all isn't it
okay professor bob i'm sorry to stop you
but uh we did have to move on but thank
you so much for your time this morning
you're welcome have a good day